Você também leva o celular pro banheiro?
Pois é, talvez seja hora de repensar
esse hábito. Um estudo publicado na
revista Plus One mostrou que usar o
celular no banheiro pode aumentar em até
46% o risco de ter hemorroidas. Isso
mesmo. Os pesquisadores perceberam que
quem leva o telefone costuma ficar muito
mais tempo sentado no vaso, às vezes
mais de 5 minutos só rolando o feed. E
isso é suficiente para causar problema.
Então, ficar sentado por muito tempo faz
pressão nas veias da região retal, o que
pode levar a dilatação, inflamação, dor
até sangramento. E o curioso é que o
risco se manteve alto mesmo quando
controlaram fatores comidade, peso,
dieta, exercício, ou seja, é o tempo
sentado, o grande vilão aqui. Então, da
próxima vez que for o banheiro, deixa o
celular lá fora. Além de evitar
hemorroides, você ainda ganha um
tempinho para desconectar e é o seu
corpo agradecendo.